et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
d'aller de corman bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous au député
européen europe ecologie les verts on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenter ce
matin à fabrice les cerveaux dont
bonjour fabrice vous rirez fabrice vous
représentez le groupe ebra ce sont les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence avec cette crise sanitaire
et c'est près de 1000 cas recensés hier
en france l'épidémie qui progresse et un
conseil de défense qui a lieu ce matin
réunis autour d' emmanuel macron pour
prendre de nouvelles mesures qu'est ce
que vous attendez vous comme meilleur
jeu toujours embêté quand on me pose
cette question là parce que je suis pas
épidémiologistes je suis pas médecin je
suis pas de compétences particulières et
autant que politique
j'ai pas les informations dont dispose
le j'espère le gouvernement et je vous
fait confiance au gouvernement pour
prendre les leurs la peau de chamois
moi je constate qu'à une forme quand
même enfin tout ça est un peu erratique
là on voit le président du conseil s'est
pas de défense mais du conseil
scientifique qui donnent des
informations qui se fait recadrer après
ça c'est l'ambiguïté du départ cercle
gouvernement s'est très vite mis
derrière le conseil scientifique en
disant nous on décide de rien on suit le
conseil scientifique et maintenant que
le conseil scientifique par le chef de
l'état dit à maintenant il faut pas dire
les choses comme ça au fond à savoir et
donc le cas il ya un traitement comme ça
qui est un peu et qui crée beaucoup
d'angoissé enfin on voit que nos vies
ont changé depuis six mois c'est là on
parle de choix difficiles quand même et
d'un durcissement des règles est-ce que
vous pensez que les français sont prêts
à repartir dans sa vie en vérité depuis
le début moi je trouve que les
françaises et les français sont très
haut débit sera au fond parce qu'on lit
on l'est on les disputes beaucoup en
disant faites attention soyez plus oui
il ya des images points on se dit les
gens font plus attention mais
globalement regard des preuves premier
vous dans la rue moi je suis entraîneur
la normandie et paris
je trouve que les gens font gars
vraiment font attention donc déjà faut
quand même saluer ça donc je pense que
s'il ya des décisions et si on leur
explique bien il n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient contre après
ça pose quand même la rentrée scolaire
vient
avoir lieu si on commence à reconfirmer
y compris pour les enfants mathis mois
ci qui sont pas simples au niveau
économique j'en parle même pas on parle
d'un requin finement par exemple par
zones où par classe d'âge aussi leur
confinement par classe d'âge vous en
pensez quoi j'ai un sujet avec ça parce
que la république notre pays c'est quand
même une forme de solidarité et
commencer à faire a créé un précédent où
il y aurait des mesures de coercition
des mesures de privation de liberté
confinement c'est ça qui ciblerait
qu'une partie de la population senior
part de l'âge c'est quelque chose qui me
choque dans le budget oui c'est toujours
pareil vous savez que dans les moments
de crise c'est là que parfois les états
de droit font des dérogations par
rapport à des principes fondamentaux qui
font notre notre république démocratie
et parfois ces exceptions peuvent
devenir des précédents qui ensuite
deviennent des règles donc faire très
attention quand on prend des décisions
qui ne sont pas anodines privée de
liberté
les gens en disant vous êtes obligés de
rester chez vous c'est loin d'être
anodin si c'est nécessaire à un moment
pour un intérêt supérieur qui en
l'occurrence ne pas mourir en chacun de
comprendre si ça commence à des
décisions pour forme de confort
économique ou pour par exemple sur les
seniors c'est ce qui serait le moins
pénalisants pour l'économie grandes
espèces oui mais c'est pour ça je vous
dis que la fait plus les principes
supérieurs genre de question de vie ou
de mort
c'est d'autres craignent helmand qui
retrouve vous craignez que l'économie
prenne le pas sur la santé c'est
toujours le risque que l'économie pas
seulement sur la santé que l'économie on
en parlera peut-être sur les questions
d'environnement sur les questions de
droits sociaux c'est quel sacrifice
concentrons-nous à un modèle économique
qu'est ce qu'il est et qui n'apporte pas
que des réponses positives donc oui
c'est des questions qu'il faut jamais
cesser de se poser
ça va me klein qui avait écrit un livre
sur la stratégie du choc
certes souvent les questions de droits
fondamentaux ils sont grignotées dans
les moments de crise certes les moments
de crise sont une opportunité pour
grignoter ses trois fleurs annoncé sa
fédération fai que havas on va accepter
en tant que citoyen qu'on nous prive pas
semblant de liberté
donc faut toujours très vigilant par
rapport à ça il ya des principes
fondamentaux
encore une fois
de droits humains de république et c'est
qu'il faut pas grignoter de façon
inconsidérée
un dernier mot sur ce sujet puisque vous
parlez de communication tout à l'heure
les parlementaires socialistes par
exemple ils réclament une communication
quotidienne comme c'était le cas du
temps des douars filet parce que vous
aussi c'est votre demande
j'en sais rien j'ai pas d'avis
franchement là dessus parce que trop de
communication à un moment les gens s'ils
perdent parce que on a l'impression que
si on aimait tous les jours quelque
chose j'en le reçoivent mais en fait les
gens ils ont une vie à côté donc et ils
vont entendre l'information en décalage
en plus on ne connaît pas encore
parfaitement ce virus donc ce qui est
dit et on peut reprocher à personne à un
moment peut être autre chose qu'un jour
après parce qu'on a fait de nouvelles
découvertes bon je suis pas sûr qu'il
faille multiplier la communication à
bien le parcours est ce qu'il ya trop de
communication beaucoup beaucoup estiment
que cette abondance de communication
nuit aussi à la gestion mais ça c'est un
problème plus large c'est qu'on est dans
ce qu'on appelle la société du spectacle
est donc parfois la politique a tendance
à utiliser l'actualité pour faire une
débauche de mise en scène de soi même y
compris en dehors du sujet qui le
préoccupe le président l'a en partie
faire au début de la crise donc tout ça
crée plus de confusion que de clarté
dans les périodes de crise il faut de la
clarté
y compris une parole qui peut être plus
rares mais qu'ils soient claires allez
on va parler de la crise sociale fabrice
oui la crise sociale les suppressions de
postes se multiplient
est ce que est ce qu'on peut trouver un
frein à sa est ce qu'il ya des sk des
solutions pour éviter ça mais oui il ya
des solutions structurelles des
solutions conjoncturelles sur les
solutions conjoncturelles c'est quand
une période de crise il faut cibler les
aides dont on dispose pour conditionnées
au maintien de l'emploi
ce cas pas été tout à fait feu et c'est
pas que nouveau quand il ya eu la mise
en place de ce qu'on appelle cic sous
l'ancien le gouvernement s'était tout de
même 20 milliards d'euros par an tout ça
a été augmentée depuis de nouvelles
aides dans le cadre du plan de relance
de dix milliards d'euros de baisse de
charges pour les entreprises ont été
décidées sans contrepartie et donc moi
ça me dérange pas qu'on aide les
entreprises mais quand il ya une
intervention d'argent public pour aider
les entreprises privées il faut des
contreparties environnementale et en
termes de maintien de l'emploi
un exemple auchan a indiqué qu'ils
allaient se séparer de plus de 1000
emplois le secteur de la grande
distribution à ma connaissance n'a pas
tellement souffert du confinement
les gens ont fait des courses ils sont
restés ouverts le modèle était en crise
avant coronavirus le créditer modernité
en crise mais pendant la crise à
proprement parler les supermarchés à ma
connaissance sont restés ouverts pendant
que vaut leur âge et à son actionnaire à
vous juger qu'il ya des abus là
aujourd'hui
oui je pense qu'à des effets d'aubaine
et au chant par rapport à le cic et
cetera entre tous de mémoire c'est 500
millions d'euros dead public d'impôts
qu'ils ont touché autant de crédits
d'impôt et donc c'est pas normal quand
on a autant dead de licenciés surtout
que tu leur dis dans la période ils ont
pas c'est pas eux qui ont
particulièrement souffert de la crise du
coffee donc à une forme de cynisme
d'opportunisme de la part de certain
nombre de grands groupes
pour profiter de ces jeunes comment il
va être franc c'est à dire que l'état
doit demander un remboursement des aides
publiques aux entreprises à bord faut
conditionner ou à l'époque du cicr est
depuis à chaque fois on a 10 mai ok vous
aider mais à quelles conditions
si on aide les entreprises pour dire on
a besoin de vous changer de modèle
économique pour respecter les questions
environnementales et de droits sociaux
c'est normal de les aider à faire cette
transition si on leur donne de l'argent
en disant vous fait confiance on est sûr
que vous en ferez bon usage
on voit ce qui se passe pendant cette
période
crise les 25 plus riche qu'il s'agit pas
de toujours mais les 25 plus riches de
cette planète ont magasiné 250 milliards
d'euros l'enrichissement pendant la même
période les plus pauvres ce sont sont
devenues encore plus pauvres donc ce
modèle là il n'est pas dur à passer pour
le conjoncturel et pour le structurel il
faut réfléchir à un blanc qui fait
évoluer notre économie les verts depuis
des années propose un plan d'un million
d'emplois sur la question énergétique
rénovation
ça c'est énormément d'emplois et
développement des énergies renouvelables
ça a été quantifié c'est un million
d'emplois
enfin il faut investir au départ pour
amorcer la pompe et ça on n'en voit pas
la couleur dans le plan de relance ce
qui est proposé sur la rénovation du
bâtiment s'est notoirement insuffisants
note up non seulement par rapport aux
nombres de passoires thermiques qu'il y
a mais par rapport à ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour créer quand même 30 milliards
dans le plan de relance pour ces
questions de transition écologique pour
vous c'est comme c'est quand même un
gage le premier round mais pas assez non
c'est sans doute pas assez mais au delà
de ça ce qui est intéressant dans le
plan de relance si on veut en dire un
mot c'est que les mesures dont vous
parlez de 30 milliards elles sont
ponctuels c'est un fusil à un coup
fait pour les deux ans qui viennent par
contre les 10 milliards de baisses de
charges pour les entreprises ça c'est
pas ponctuelle s'est annoncée pour être
durable ils sont allés dissonance
cognitive sire que ce qu'il faudrait
qu'il soit durable
c'est les mesures écologiques ce qui
devrait porter ses les aides aux
entreprises parce qu'il ya une crise oc
on fait le contraire ce qui est
ponctuelle c'est l'écologie c'est la
transition écologique qu'il faut sur
dans la durée ce qui est durable
c'est les aides aux entreprises sans
condition allez vous parliez de ce plan
de relance à la france qui présentera à
ce plan de relance a à l'union
européenne courant octobre puisque 40
milliards des 100 milliards du plan de
relance vient seront financés par
l'union européenne l'union européenne
qui aura donc son mot à dire sur ce plan
de relance est ce que vous vous le vôtre
et ce plan de relance est député
européen
oui oui alors je suis la commission
budget du parlement européen donc on
suit ses affaires quand vous dites
l'union européenne va donner sur l'union
européenne ces trois entités 1 et la
commission c'est le gouvernement d'union
il ya le conseil ça c'est important de
l'avoir en tête c'est les états c'est
les fameuses états nations c'est le
comble
pouvoir non ce dont on parle et il ya le
parlement celle où c'est pas moi c'est
doux c'est pas la république c'est vrai
bon bref et donc nous le parlement dans
ces affaires de budget on à la co
décision finale tient qu'à la fin le
parlement et le droit de dire oui ou non
mais c'est le conseil qui propose or là
on a un problème parce que s'il est
d'être con si ce plan de relance de 750
milliards dont 390 milliards de
subventions qui est c'était ça la
nouveauté c'est ça la nouveauté plutôt
que ça soit l'état qu'on bénéficie qui
rembourse lui même c'est le collectif
c'est en mutualisant cette dette qu'est
ce que ça veut dire mutualiser la dette
sert qu'à la place que l'état paye c'est
le budget de l'union qui va rembourser
ce prêt en ce moment ça tombe bien on
discute du budget pluriannuel de l'union
sir l'argent du budget européen pour les
sept prochaines années
il faut comprendre que ce budget pour
financer le fameux green deal le plan
vert européen le numérique qui était la
feuille de route avant même le coc vide
de la commission du gouvernement
il fallait augmenter ce budget
pluriannuel qui aujourd'hui est assez
limité or depuis le plan de relance le
conseil nous dit dit au parlement
ah mais nous on finance déjà le plan de
relance on va pas pouvoir augmenter le
budget pluriannuel
pire on va le bc et donc on a un
problème c'est que pour le plan de
relance on va sacrifier des politiques
structurelles de l'union
c'est la même idée que précédemment
cercle au nom de l'urgence on simplifie
l'important alors qu'il faut faire
évidemment les deux et donc la grande
bataille qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est de
dire que plutôt que ça soit le budget de
l'union via les contributions des états
c'est-à-dire les contribuables européens
qui paient qui finance cette affaire il
faut des nouvelles ressources
ce qu'on appelle les ressources propres
parce qu'aujourd'hui le parlement fin le
budget de l'union européen il est
financé à 75% par des dotations des
états l'a 25 ans c'était que des
recettes propres de l'union
elles ont disparu parce qu'on a supprimé
les frontières les traités de libre
échange dont il ya plus de droits de
dépôt de droits de douane donc
aujourd'hui nous serons 10 c'est que
pour financer le plan de relance et les
budgets à venir pour qu'on ait plus de
budget européen
il faut fiscalisés pas les quidams pas
les citoyens
mais ce qui aujourd'hui est
chapalain peau c'est la transaction de
la taxe sur la transaction financière
c'est la taxe sur les gars femme quelle
femme ces grands groupes qui se seront
aussi beaucoup pour enrichis pendant la
crise amazon facebook etc
il faut la taxe carbone aux frontières
toutes ces idées de nouvelle fiscalité
qui s'attaque à ceux qui aujourd'hui
échappent à l'impôt et s'enrichissent
c'est celle qu'il faut créer aujourd'hui
le conseil s'est car les états nous
disent non nous ne voulons pas créer ces
nouvelle fiscalité juste donc on a ce
combat là et donc je souhaite si désolée
pour cette longue digression mais je
souhaite que le parlement
si nous n'avons pas ces nouvelles
ressources qui permettent d'avoir une
fiscalité juste qui finance la
transition qui finance la résidence il
faut dire non il faut dire on conseille
ça suffit c'est pas les budgets à venir
les politiques structurelles européennes
qui vont financer votre plan de relance
sinon c'est un plan de relance que vous
nous dites est faux semblants il faut
revoir au final quasiment le
fonctionnement
de l'union c'est sur le coup ce plan de
relance sur lequel vous aurez à vous
prononcer à très court terme de coût
pour vous ça sera non abbas il n'y a pas
ce que je vous dise il n'y a pas la
fiscalité juste c'est pas vraiment un
plan de relance vous pensez avoir une
réponse sur ces questions complexes et
la bataille qui s'annonce et la bataille
qui se mène au moment assure en ce
moment même si vous via les
parlementaires il ya tout le parlement
s'est pas que les écolos qui disent ça
quand je dis nous c'est 75% du parlement
européen donc de la droite juste qu'elle
a un goût et la gauche européennes où il
ya la france est soumise par un peu tout
le monde dit on veut des ressources
propres
on veut des conditionnalités écologique
on veut à un certain nombre de sujets
dont les ressources propres et s'il n'y
a pas ça on ne soutiendra pas le plan de
relance autre bataille qui est en train
de se mener au parlement européen c'est
la bataille entre strasbourg et
bruxelles pour parler des palaces et la
presse de l'est qui est facilement pas
seulement est ce que est ce qu'il va y
avoir un effet d'aubaine napoléon pour
les belges
il n'aura pas d'effet d'aubaine parce
que on pose souvent la question
strasbourg et moi je voudrais pas que
nous soyons les petits français les
petites françaises dans leur citadelle
assiégée qu'on peur qu'on leur pique
leur siège de strasbourg
c'est impossible c'est impossible
d'arrêter strasbourg pourquoi c'est
parce que c'est dans les traités et dans
les traités il ya écrit qu'il ya douze
sessions parlementaires parents qui se
tiennent à strasbourg est la seule
manière pour que y ait plus de parlement
à strasbourg c'est qu'il faudra qu'un
président de la république française qui
signe un changement des traités ce qui
n'arrivera pas donc en fait
strasbourg restera vous êtes serein oui
mais je sens la fébrilité et vous avez
raison il ya parfois des petites
mesquineries nos collègues d'autres pays
qui se dit là bas ça se passe très bien
quand on va plus à strasbourg et ça mais
faut rester très serein avec sa
strasbourg une très belle ville la maire
de strasbourg jeunes marseillan et
constamment en contact avec monsieur
sassoli quel président du parlement pour
faire pression pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ambiguïté parce que le sujet c'est pas
seulement de garder le parlement à
strasbourg je vous ai dit ça sera le cas
c'est d'accueillir de bonnes conditions
et que tout le monde soit content d'y
aller ça tombe bien strasbourg est une
très belle ville donc y a pas
d'inquiétude à avoir là-dessus
allez on va parler des écologistes en
rien maire écologiste qui a beaucoup
fait parler de lui ces dernières heures
c'est le nouveau maire
de lyon grégory un tour de chauffe et
qui va accueillir le tour de france
demain mais qui le grégory dorcel a
quelque peu fustigé un seul tour de
france il le juge machiste et polluant
vous êtes d'accord
vous savez c'est les mots qu'il a
utilisée mais derrière les mots il ya
une réalité le tour de france c'est
l'événement sportif annuel le plus
important du monde il ya deux événements
sportifs mais qui sont pas nouvelles qui
sont plus suivis c'est les jeux
olympiques et la coupe du monde de foot
donc en fait quand on est un événement
sportif de cette porte et là ça ne donne
pas que des droits
ça donne aussi des devoirs parce que il
ya une symbolique dernière qui et
prescriptrice les gens prennent pour
modèle à juste titre cette compétition
sportive extraordinaire qui non
seulement met en valeur le vélo mais met
en valeur aussi notre pays donc c'est
pas anodin et c'est à ce titre là qu'on
a le droit se poser des questions sur
quel rapport à quel modèle de
consommation il met en valeur
quelle empreinte écologique à
l'événement lui-même quel imaginaire il
met en valeur dire le tour de france oui
même à changer un petit peu c'est à dire
que avant les champions se voyait
remettre leurs maillots par deux femmes
ou que voilà et là aujourd'hui
ils ont compris que ça envoyait un jeune
homme ou une femme meurt le diable pour
remettre les maillots de la thaïlande
ont quelques choses peuvent changer le
tour de france je pense à vocation à
changer parce que c'est justement un
événement j'aurais pu les utiliser
non mais j'invite tout le monde à lire
l'interview en entier c'est normal quand
on titre on regarde les mots le plus
shop et dans le contexte with his ils
sont utilisés justement mais derrière
encore une fois ces deux mots là il faut
pas s'empêcher de réfléchir sur le fond
pour l'événement du tour de france mais
comme d'autres d'autres événements
sportifs
de la même manière puisque nous parlons
de monsieur douce et la question
religieuse cette semaine puisque grégory
doute c'est n'a pas voulu participer
comme l'avait fait ses prédécesseurs ou
non été échevin et en même temps à poser
la première pierre de la mosquée de
gerland est ce que il y à a lyon une
chez les écologistes un problème avec la
question religieuse et savez qu'il ya un
maire de lyon extrêmement fameux qui n'a
jamais participé à cette manifestation
des élections et qui s'appelle edouard
herriot qui a été maire de lyon pendant
presque 50 ans avant et après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et visiblement ça n'a choqué personne
ailleurs c'est logique monsieur herriot
était un radical de gauche est donc très
attaché à la laïcité
donc oui les écologistes sont très
attachés à la question laïque le lien
que vous faites avec la mosquée le dépôt
de la première pierre d'une mosquée je
pense que c'est ça dont il s'agit est un
peu particulier il s'agit pas là de
participer en tant que maire à une
cérémonie religieuse
il s'agit de permettre à ce que les
croyants et c'est ça la laïcité français
puissent non puissent pratiquer leur foi
la laïcité en france elle permet ça
c'est la liberté de croire et de ne pas
croire et quand on croit à partir de
manga pas d'ingérence dans la vie
collective dans la vie politique
collective de pouvoir pratiquer sa foi
et donc dans la mesure où il ya des
musulmans prier il est logique qu'ils
aient des lieux pour pouvoir pratiquer
leur foi mais il n'y a pas d'équivalence
entre les deux exemples que vous donnez
il y avait une manifestation religieuse
auxquelles en tant qu'élu de la
république qui considèrent à juste titre
à mon avis ne pas avoir à participer et
à la pose d'une pierre pour que des
croyants puissent pratiquer leur foi
donc ces deux choses pour moi très
différentes questions sur la prochaine
échéance électorale pour les écologistes
ce sont les sénatoriales qui auront lieu
dans moins d'un jour maintenant ils
n'ont pas de groupes écologistes
il n'y a pas de groupes écologiques de
plus n'a à l'heure actuelle il y en a
plus que vous êtes confiant sur le
retour d'un groupe écologiste au sénat
oui oui je suis raisonnablement confiant
d'abord parce que l'on ne vient me
parler de nos victoire aux municipales
ce qui nous permet d'avoir c'est un mode
de scrutin en particulier enfin ce
qu'hydro garde je pense que ça à
l'esprit vu le nom de votre chaîne mais
c'est pas tout le monde qui votent donc
il faut gagner des collectivités pour
pouvoir avoir des grands électeurs des
grandes séductrices et c'est donc là oui
on a l'opportunité j'espère de gagner
dessinatrice et des sénateurs là où nous
nous n'avions pas parce que dans cette
partie le renouvellement du sénat
on en avait
zéro donc en principe on devrait faire
mieux tout cas on fera papillon mais
n'ont jamais mais pas assez pour faire
un gros permet dans ce renouvellement on
en avait pas sur ce qu'on a fait qu'est
ce qu'on est élu dans l'autre partie de
moi est donc là oui j'espère qu'on en
verra 5,6 pour pouvoir avec ton fier
d'avoir dix membres pour faire avoir un
groupe au sénat je souhaite et c'est
souhaitable c'est souhaitable pour la
vie démocratique du sénat qui puisse y
avoir un groupe parlementaire écologiste
qui porte ses idées qu'ils aient les
moyens de le faire et l'autre échéance
en mars
cette fois ce sont les régionales ont un
mot sur sur l'île de france est ce que
julien bayou qui s'est déclarée en tout
cas qui s'est déclaré candidat à cette
élection est ce qu'il n'est pas parti
trop tôt est ce qu'il n'est pas en train
de faire barrage à une union de la
gauche pour contrer valérie pécresse
savez on nous a dit ça au municipal
quand on a commencé à faire des listes
les régionales c'est un scrutin
proportionnel à deux tours
tant qu'il permet c'est bien aussi en
démocratie pouvoir avoir le choix au
premier tour et ensuite de se rassembler
au deuxième à la lumière de ce qu'auront
se décider les citoyens estoniens
premier tournant tout ça est un
processus j'ai envie de dire normal et
apprennent qu'il y aura une candidature
écologiste en ile de france comme
partout à kiel en soi comme partout et
après rien n'empêche que y ait un
rassemblement plus large qui se fasse
autour de l'écologie mais exactement ce
qui s'est passé aux municipales il y
avait des stratégies un peu différente
mais dont la ligne directrice était un
projet écologiste proposé aux électrices
et aux électeurs et j'espère que ça
marchera que ça marchera bien elle est
un dernier mot pour finir fabrice sur ce
rapport de la wwf qui a été rendue ces
jours ci ben oui ce rapport qui indique
que
les populations de vertébrés donc ça
comprend les oiseaux le poisson vous
connaissez le sujet et mammifères ont
chuté de 68% entre 70 et 2016
j'imagine que vous faites partie déjà
des de ces déçus du monde d'après dont
on nous parlait avant pendant le
confinement
on sort de ceux en sorte de ce
confinement et on s'aperçoit que il ya
un déclin en tout cas qui est qui est
indiquée par ces rapports
comment on fait est ce qu est ce qu on
peut inverser cette tendance à l'horizon
2100 puisque c'est sa l'inquiétude il
faut commencer même avant donc d'accord
ces chiffres sont effrayants il faut
comprendre qui s'accélère un wwf et un
rapport je crois là dessus tous les 2-3
ans et quant au fur et à mesure qu'on
avance la rapidité à laquelle on assiste
à un déclin donc des vertébrés mais
aussi des insectes les papillons ont
décru de 50 % en 30 ans en europe
c'est un indicateur redoutable de
l'extinction de la vie notamment de la
vie sauvage sur notre planète et c'est
un indicateur évidemment qui doit qui
doit nous effrayer mais vous avez vu le
rapport est sorti en même temps que ces
images absolument incroyable
en californie des feux et à san
francisco vous avez peut-être en tête
ces images dystopique enfin dans le
futur effrayant c'est intéressant parce
que la californie c'est
la cinquième puissance du monde mais
c'est aussi de là dont elle est partie
via hollywood
l'american way of life tiens la société
de consommation qu'un train de devenir
une société de consommation au sens
propre et donc c'est vrai en californie
c'est vrai avec l'extinction
alors vous me demandez ce qu'on est au
brésil haussière oui oui mais est-ce
qu'on peut agir oui on peut agir en
changeant de modèle agricole -2
d'alimentation carnet puisque très
souvent notamment si vous parlez du
brésil c'est pour établir des cultures
ce qui nourrit ensuite le bétail un
modèle agricole qui arrêtent d'utiliser
par exemple les néonicotinoïdes on voit
bien dans le calendrier on continue de
s'inquiéter de conséquences dans ton
chéri les causes et c'est sa voix qui me
paraît le font chez celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont la charge de prendre des
décisions politiques ou un impact direct
là dessus c'est quand on continue à
avoir des relations économiques avec des
pays qui détruisent sur les pesticides
on n'avance pas donc on a même reculé on
a reculé hier qu entre la loi pompili
2016 et la proposition de loi pompili
2020 on recule
c'est même pas qu'on fait pas de céder
petit c'est même pas des pas trop court
ses confrères en arrière c'est fou et
merci beaucoup merci david merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin lundi à votre
place ce sera un autre député européen
ce sera nicolas bay député européen
membre du rassemblement national merci
d'avoir été avec nous c'est tout de
suite leur du club des territoires